[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute vereinen wir mal
zwei richtig beliebte Dinge und zwar
Cinnamon Rolls und Bananenbrot also
machen wir ein cinnamon Roll inspired
banana bread ich weiß g nicht warum ich
jetzt Englisch Rede aber auf englisch
hört sich halt immer alles cool an so
ich starte direkt und schreibe euch wie
immer alle ganz genau Mengen ich
schreibe euch alle ganz genau
Mengenangaben hier unten in die Infobox
hier gebe ich jetzt erstmal zimmerwarme
Butter in die Schüssel meiner
Küchenmaschine na geh runter und ihr
könnt auch euer handrühgerät benutzen
ich find es mit der Küchenmaschine
einfach ein bisschen entspannter so da
kommt jetzt auch schon Zucker mit dazu
und Vanille extra könnt ihr auch schon
mit dazu geben sowie die Prise Salz die
hebt noch mal den süßen Geschmack und
macht noch mal alles schön rund das
ganze dann 2 D Minuten lang schön cremig
mixen und in der Zwischenzeit verrühre
ich hier schon mal die paar trockenen
Zutaten miteinander und zeratsche auch
schon mal die
[Musik]
reifenbananen die Eier kommen jetzt mit
dazu also erstmal quasi die flüssigen
Zutaten und die Eier am besten so lange
verrühren bis sie sich einigermaßen
verbunden haben wenn Sie sich nicht ganz
verbinden ist das nicht schlimm denn mit
der Zugabe der nächsten Zutat wird sich
auf jeden Fall alles miteinander
vermengen so danach kommen dann die
Bananen dazu die habe ich hier mit der
Gabel zerstampft eigentlich ist es so je
reifer desto süßer also auch desto
besser daher wenn ihr schon so Bananen
habt die richtig braun sind verwendet
die gerne und ganz zum Schluss kommt
dann auch noch der Joghurt als letzte
flüssige Zutat dazu eh dann die
trockenen Zutaten dazu kommt die haben
wir ja schon vorab verrührt damit sich
das besser miteinander vermengt also
mehl Backpulver und simt aber ihr müsst
euch das ja alles nicht merken steht ja
wie gesagt alles in der
Infobox
[Musik]
ganz wichtig ist wenn ihr die trocknen
Zutaten ganz zum Schluss dazu gebt nicht
länger als maximal 10 Sekunden rühren
denn wir rühren wirklich nur so viel wie
notwendig aber nicht überrühren weil ich
finde so ist der Tag einfach tausend Mal
fluffiger ich finde das sieht man jetzt
auch schon im rohen Zustand ich habe
jetzt hier meine eckige Springform mit
Backpapier ausgekleidet gebe jetzt hier
einmal die Hälfte mit dazu das ist jetzt
hier richtig richtig leckerer
bananenbrotteig und da kommt noch mal so
eine extra cinnamon Note dazu nicht nur
später mit dem cream cheese Frosting
sondern eben jetzt auch indem wir
einfach Zimt und Zucker miteinander
verrühren und dann so in die Mitte geben
und dann kommt quasi der zweite teig
noch mal oben drüber und dann machen wir
eine Sour jetzt rein und Ofen habe ich
auch schon vorgeheizt verrate euch auch
noch die
Backzeit
die Backzeit war jetzt bei 180° Ober und
Unterhitze 60 Minuten und jetzt löse ich
einmal den Rand meiner Springform so
ganz vorsichtig ich habe jetzt auch noch
ein bisschen abkühlen lassen übrigens so
und jetzt einfach runternehmen vom
Backpapier dann tue ich ih auf so eine
schöne Servierplatte und dann kommt noch
unser cream cheese Frosting das kommt
auch auf cinamon noch mal oben drüber
das besteht einfach nur hier aus
Doppelrahm Frischkäse ein bisschen
Puderzucker so ein bisschen ist gut das
Verhältnis ist dann schon ein bisschen
höher aber dadurch dass das hier nicht
ganz so süß ist ist das ein toller
Ausgleich und ich gebe noch
Vanilleextrakt mit dazu und geb das
einfach oben drüber und dann sind wir
auch schon
[Musik]
fertig
so ich habe jetzt noch dekoriert mit
getrockneten Bananenchips und mit
Schokodrops und das ist mal ganz
spannend weil Schokodrops sind dann nach
einer Zeit Hal immer total grau das ist
ganz normal wegen des
temperaturunterschieds da wird der
Schokolade immer sehr schnell grau und
da gibt's halt ein einfachen Trick ihr
nehmt euch das in die Hand und gibt
einfach ein bisschen Handwärme also
quasi so ein bisschen reiben in den
Handinnenflächen und dann sollten sie
wieder richtig schön aussehen guck mal
hier so zum
Vergleich so sehen die halt aus wenn die
dann aus der Verpackung kommen und wir
nehmen dann die Variante weil die ein
bisschen appetitlicher
aussieht so es gibt cinnamon Roll banana
in Hand geklatscht damit der synchron
ist
ach ja passt doch hier banan Bananenbrot
ja ja dann würde ich mal sagen gönn dir
find man sieht
den nur Bananenbrot also Bananen und
eigentlich finde ich Bananenbrot ist
Bananenkuchen also Brot eigentlich
nichts zu
tunot das riecht man auch schon
ne süß aus mit der Schokolade und so ich
auch und ich finde
sorim len unter ich wei ich rede jetzt
viel aber sieht
tollag das ist lustig immer wenn wir
Test machen inspizieren wir beide erst
die Optik dann so die Konsistenz und
dann
[Musik]
probieren
weiß Bananenbrot hast du oh richtig
lecker also wenn ich RA manchmal esse
oder so oder keine Ahnung dann ist
meistens voll so dann schmeckt es e echt
wie so ein Brot so ze aber der ist schön
weich ja der ist echt weich find aber
unnormal saftig fin das sieht man aber
auch beim Anschnitt der schmeckt richtig
richtig lecker Leute überhaupt nicht
trocken überhaupt nicht findest du ih zu
süß süß oder zu süß ich finde ich
schmeck komm süß weil ich habe im Teig
halt verhältnismäßig weniger Zucker
verhältnismäßig und dann habe ich hier
quasi im Frosting Vanille so ein
bisschen Puderzucker und ich finde das
der perfekte Ausgleich das sch richtig
lecker aber ich find auch das Frosting
allgemein normalweise mach man gerne
Frosting drauf be bbrot ne eigentlich
neeoll ich jetzt auch noch nicht
gegessen aber das schmeckt voll lecker
wolltest so eine Zimtschnecke ja wollte
gerade sagen das hat bisschen zimsnecken
Charakter weß ich auch gut ich weiß
nicht ob du es gemerkt hast ne aber
dadurch D es angebacken ist auf dem
Boden eigentlich oh nein ich meine nur
es ist so angebacken ne man hat halt
wirklich so eine so eine ich will nicht
sagen crunchy aber man hat schon so eine
Kruste in also unten und oben und dann
hat man innen drin dieses saftige und
das so in Kombination als Mundgefühl
zusammen mit dem Frosting richtig lecker
mit den schokoträpchen auch mm das
minidee ich finde eher die
schokotrppchen die geen süße alles
andere ist gar nicht süß überhaupt nicht
das Frosting ist schon ja ist bisschen
süß ja klar also aber so richtig passend
einfach aber der Ken
nee der Kuchen ist gar nicht süß
überhaupt nicht ne finde ich überhaupt
nicht perfekt boah Leute richtig lecker
ich bin verliebt macht es unbedingt nach
ich verlinke euch auch gerne mal mein
klassisches Bananenbrot Rezept in die
Infobox ich sag dir sogar schmeckt
besser als das klassische banenbrot find
ich auch ehrlich finde ich auch ja ich
mir auch gedacht das haben wir während
Corona hochzeitenase gebacken ja also
macht's unbedingt nach und hinterlasst
einen Kommentar um uns ein bisschen zu
supporten schreibt mir auch gerne was
ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet und
schaltet gerne ein im nächsten Video
wenn nicht mehr so lik und kommentiert
dann gibt keine Videos mehr einfach voll
die Drogen hier nein wir machen
natürlich immer weiter und wir danken
natürlich auch für euren Support also
wir sind jetzt schon seit 6 Jahren auf
dem Markt Bo seit Jahren Supp sch extrem
Mar du bist nicht mehr auf Markt ich
auch nicht mehr okay ich habe zwar kein
Ering an wo trägt man eent links oder
rechts egal TR Herzen das ist wichtigste
das ist wichtig also Leute peace out
peace and out
tschüss